so Taylor Swift had transcended her role
as a mega star and emerged as an
economic Powerhouse her uh I'm sorry you
want to read this part you want to look
for page eight I think it's important
for you to read this part I love the
article because you you speak so it's an
Assyrian word but go ahead all right so
uh Taylor Swift has transcended her role
as a mega star and emerge as an economic
Powerhouse her eras tour which if you
are a Syrian you're listening has a
completely different meaning than what
the tour actually is we'll talk about
that later with resale tickets yo think
about this 3 800 for a average ticket
could generate uh 4.6 billion dollars in
consumer spending in the us alone uh the
Federal Reserve acknowledged Swift's
impact to local economies uh citing her
concerts at a catalyst for increased
Hotel Revenue in Philadelphia uh
additionally her upcoming eras store uh
or era store movie is expected to make a
100 million dollar box office splash
bolstering the struggling uh Hollywood
industry Taylor Swift's appearance in
the NFL game between Kansas City and
Chicago Bears significantly boosted the
League's popularity despite the game's
one side outcome it drew 24.3 million
average viewers with an 8.1 increase in
female viewers in the 12 to 17 year old
uh demographic female viewers and like
because Liz I want to know what you guys
opinions are so that that influence that
movement that bringing all the eyeballs
it's to go to the political side she's
obviously voiced her opinion on on
politics we all know where she stands
the guy that she's dating the first
thing he does when they start dating
he's like hey get your vax get your shot
get get your boot get get everything I'm
just it's it's it's funny to me it's
like you guys realize they're gonna
break up like I hope everybody out there
all the people that are just like oh my
God this is match made in half that's
not good it's gonna work it's gonna work
forever but Pat I don't say that I
thought about it I really thought about
it you know the breakup song is gonna
have to do with the NFL you know she's
gonna sing a song that's gonna go you
fumbled me inside the end zone that's a
penalty you're not in the friend zone
screw the Chiefs like that's gonna be
the the when they break up what's over
the hell was that that was actually good
yeah think about this and guys think
about this when she's done with him what
happens to all those viewers and the
taste of all these people's in their
mouth of the NFL what happens what
happens to the mass Exeter for swifties
because when she leaves those swifties
are coming with her like you you know
what I mean they're gonna break up for
two reasons well um number one uh he's a
fan of Andrew tateless I mean he's a big
strong strapping dude he's actually
um one of those masculine dudes that is
a fan of Tate so we'll see if that works
out but they're gonna work out uh or not
work out because of one main reason
money there's something called hypergamy
women like dating up so this might be
fun short term he's a fun cool football
guy he's worth 30 million she's worth
750 million yeah he'll be able to treat
her to dinner and take her out and treat
her nice and show her good time
but he ain't flying around on private
jets he ain't traveling all around the
world with her he ain't got it like that
now as Travis Kelsey a stud the man best
tied in the league arguably No Doubt
this is a whole nother level big time
and I I know this from experience to not
get too personal one of my best friends
dated not dated married a girl
more famous than Taylor Swift okay Kim
Kardashian and let me tell you 50
million ain't one billion of course and
at some point those billionaire type
women are going to go after billionaires
yeah but Liz you agree though I mean
like obviously this is all for politics
and you know the visual of it don't you
think like that isn't it kind of weird
that all this is happening she's opening
her mouth about politics he's telling
people to get the the new vaccine like
does it like do you see that my reaction
when I saw his vaccine ad was his
heart's gonna be broken by either the
shot or by her but it's an inevitable
conclusion yeah one way or the other one
way or the other and I I don't mean not
to credit whoever came up with that joke
I saw it on Twitter and yeah like it was
cracked me up listen Taylor Swift is
very interesting because she obviously
is outspoken about liberal politics
right leftist politics I think she's
pro-abortion I think she was against she
was against Marcia Blackburn in
Tennessee but the reason that her era's
tour is so incredibly successful like
who doesn't love Taylor Swift songs
the Syrian tour sorry Gabriel I love you
the reason it's so successful is because
while she preaches feminism politically
her entire Bank of songs are actually
anti-feminists they speak to what young
women actually desire but are told that
they culturally shouldn't so it speaks
of true love getting married having a
family running away together fairy tales
this very actually family-centric
wholesome message in most of her songs
which is a contradiction of her personal
life and her politics but I think it's
very interesting because our culture
tells like 12 year olds to 17 year old
women you should go into stem that's the
only thing you should do don't focus on
having babies right now save that for a
long time go on birth control for 15
years do that freeze your eggs save them
but what young women actually want is
they want to fall in love they want to
be wives and mothers they might have
other other goals I mean I I do both
obviously but every young woman wants
that and I think it's really interesting
that she's such a liberal personally but
she's making her money off of like
traditions
if I'm we're gonna wrap up because we we
can hit other stores it's 1102. if I'm
the CMO of MLB Tom you know what I'm
doing we're putting an entire Campaign
together for shohei Otani to date Taylor
Swift way too much eyeballs away from
the MLB and I don't appreciate it we're
going to create a breakup and his next
contract saws yes it should be like a
season of The Bachelorette but like
professional athletes which sport which
league so if you like this clip and you
want to watch another one click right
here and if you want to watch the entire
podcast click right here
[Music]